I came on before I actually read this
read the script to be honest
obviously afternoon I had phone calls
from Donald and and spoke spoke to him
there was a sort of a bit of a
negotiation whether I was going to be
available of time wise and things like
this so I agreed to do the film without
actually reading the script I didn't
want to reference the other Blade Runner
because I didn't want to sort of impose
too many ideas and things like this and
on what I was very important to see what
Donald was thinking and what Denis was
thinking and how he's thinking about his
characters and also to was Rene the
costume Rene April the costume designer
and to see where they were going to go
with everything because obviously that
plays a big part of what happens with
hair even with costumes and makeup and
and things
well after speaking basically to Jenny
and see what sort of world he wanted to
create I realize it was a very dark
world and a very sort of like all my
sort of like colorless in a sense and we
decided to make most of our characters
our principles were very dark sombre
sort of colorless hair to sort of almost
take all the all the sudden almost in a
sense take the life out of the hair you
know because it was a very humid dense
tank world that were going to be in and
to to rather than have that obvious Los
Angeles sort of blonde look we sort of
to try to take it all away so it looked
sort of in a way sort of futuristic but
not really anything that would would
really sort of stand out too much and
obviously to to create the look with
after discussing with Denis was sort of
almost to go back to go forward you
notice or would want a jaw the eye we
didn't want to make it look sci-fi we
didn't want to make it look too edgy
almost a world that sort of identifiable
that you could possibly people could be
in obviously prepping I used to sort of
a lot of wings to prep Denis doesn't
like wigs it's big
not many directors do
and what was sort of interesting one of
the first looks we did was as Anna Anna
Damas as the pinko once she was one of
the first looks we were doing and we're
discussing what color hair she should
have obviously she was going to have
pink skin and we didn't know at that
point what color pink but I was working
on as on a just of stop shop brought wig
that I was we were coloring in them a in
the hair and makeup department and it's
sort of like putting different tones and
different shades and things and
basically that's what actually we
finished up using on camera because we
by the time we didn't really have enough
time because we shot a lot of those
things in prep so by the time it had
been decided yes this is the skin colour
this is where we're gonna go with hair
we didn't have time to have anything
made that was it
basically and that was so sort of like
something I've got off the shelf in a
store somewhere but when we colored it
was a blonde one when we colored because
who who wanted to not look like shop
bought of seaweed but it was sort of
full like we wanted a multi toned and
sort of slightly in purple with pink
highlights in and things like this well
basically we had 52 actors coming
through so I was looking after Robin on
set and Anna I was around but I wasn't
physically on set every day I was sort
of prepping cutting wigs organizing what
looks testing the other actresses are
coming through because we'd often often
like Donald said would get them sort of
like 24 hours before they're going on
camera and we had to come up with a look
you know and obviously it sort of saved
the day with Denis not liking weeks
because we knew we couldn't really go
there so other than Mariette one of our
characters who was she was on a TV
series we couldn't cut her hair we
couldn't change the color we couldn't do
anything yet she was on going to be
filmed for about six weeks so we decided
to use obviously with a wig with her
well the limitations was also with the
CGI because I had to keep their hair is
sort of contained and it wasn't about
big hair so we good so we could morph
the characters into one another like
Mariette and
and joy into one another so if it had
been a sort of like a bigger look it
would have been to distill disturbing to
the eye so we kept the hair quite close
to the head also if we were in a very
humid atmosphere so it wasn't about hair
big hair or a lot of hair because
otherwise it would have died on set
anyway so basically the idea was to keep
it quite close and quite
streamlined you know stream like
actually in a sense you know even with
Robin Wright sort of just slicked back
almost like sort of slightly androgynous
looking and most of her girls without
really a lot of big hairdo numbers was
almost pulling it back and making it
look a little bit more believable the
only sort of extreme parts where our
Vegas scenes where we had sort of
showgirls and sixties sort of go-go
dancers and Elvis Presley Liberace and
those those were a little bit more
extreme they were sort of our sort of a
playing area really
[Music]